So what do you want to eat for lunch?
I still don't know yet...
...but mom said that I have to make sure that I eat a healthy meal every day.
How do you do that?
My food should have one go food, one grow food and one glow food.
Go, grow and glow food?
What are those?
Food can be grouped into three groups.
Go, grow and glow.
Go food gives us energy.
This kind of food contains carbohydrates like rice, bread, cereals and noodles.
These help us run, jump and play all day.
Grow food makes us grow bigger and stronger.
It helps in the development of muscles.
This kind of food gives us protein.
Examples are meat, fish, milk, and egg.
Glow food makes us look good.
This kind of food makes our skin glow, our hair shine and our eyes sparkle.
It gives us vitamins and minerals.
Examples are fruits and vegetables.
Now I know what a healthy meal is made of.
I think I'll eat a sandwich today.
It has bread, meat, lettuce, and tomatoes.
Thanks, Candy.
I learned a lot from you today.
You're welcome, Dave.
Learning is always fun.
Let's go eat!
Did you have fun learning about go, grow and glow foods?